Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Ute Ergid und heute bin ich der
Disziplinterarzt auf der Sichtstation. Ich möchte mit Ihnen gerne das
Erstgespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Guten Abend Herr Doktor Herr Doktor. Ja ja natürlich.
Ja. Ich werde zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir auch sofort zu Ihrem Beschwerden. Wenn Sie etwas nicht
verstehen können oder eine Frage haben, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder
fragen Sie nach. Okay. Vielen Dank. Wie heißen Sie denn? Mein Name ist
Sarah. Ja. Ihr Name oder Vorname ist Sarah. Sarah ist mein
Vorname. Und wie ist Ihr Nachname? Ja mein Nachname ist Kantha.
Kantha. Frau Kantha, könnten Sie bitte Ihr Nachnamen Buch
stabilen? Ja ganz einfach. KBK, AW, Anton, North Pole,
Theodor, Emil, Richard. Okay. Vielen Dank. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 22 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie? Um ungefähr 1 Meter 72.
Wissen Sie, wie viel wiegen? Ja ja ich habe mich heute Morgen auf die
Lage gestellt. Ich bin so ungefähr 55 kg. Vielen Dank für die
Informationen. Frau Kantha, was für eine heute zu uns, wie kann ich Ihnen
helfen? Ach Doktor, ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube ich bin etwas gestresst.
Wir sind gestresst. Warum haben Sie gestresst? Ja ich kann nicht so
sagen. Ich habe nächste Woche Prüfungen und vielleicht war das
einfach zu viel und der ganze Prüfung, Prüfungsvorbereitung.
Ich bin immer so schlecht. Luft. Okay, dann sind Sie unter Wurst
schmeißen? Nein, nein, aber ich kann seit 3-4 Tagen kaum
schlafen, Herr Doktor. Und ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber ich
glaube, das ist einfach viel Stress und es bekommt schlecht
Luft und meine Hände sind ganz komisch und ich habe Schmerzen in
den Füßen. Die ganzen Gelenke tun mir weh.
Sie haben Schirkheit beim Einatmen oder? Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, ich
kriege einfach schlecht Luft. Schlecht Luft. Okay, seit 3-4 Tagen
schon so. Seit 2-3 Tagen. Ja so.
Auch Fragante, okay.
Fragante möchte ich unser Gespräch unterbringen und ihr Lunge abholen und ihr
Sauerstoffstätigung messen. Gerne, ja.
Ja, dann wir können unser Gespräch fortsetzen. Okay.
Ja, können wir fortsetzen? Ja, Lunge ist frei, Sauerstoffstätigung 96 Prozent.
6 und 90.
Danke, Frau Kantag. So, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit 3-4 Tagen
Schirkheiten beim Einatmen und Schmerzen in Füße oder? Ja, also
mehr, das sind so die Hände, die sind ganz komisch. Ich habe das
Gefühl, ich bekomme Kribbeln und Krämpfe in den Händen. Okay, in
Hände, Kribbeln und ich habe das Gefühl, dass mir die Füße auch
so kribbeln und manchmal wieder ein Krampf, also wenn ich
laufe, tut es weh, auch in der Wade. Das ist irgendwie ganz komisch.
Ich habe gedacht, da sind Ameisen oder mich haben Insekten gestochen, aber
da ist nichts. Aber manchmal sind die Füße wie verkrampft.
Okay, nur in Füße oder auch im Beine? Nein, nur in Füßen, ein bisschen die
Wade auf beiden Seiten, aber auch die Hände sind ganz, ganz komisch.
Ich kriege so manchmal Krämpfe in der Hände, dann kann die nicht auch richtig aufmachen.
Okay. Und ganz gut, ich habe so ein ganz komisches Gefühl im Gesicht, manchmal habe
er so im Mundbereich das Kribbelt und ich kriege, ich habe das Gefühl, ich bekomme keine Luft.
Okay, sind diese Beschwerden erstes mal auftreten? Ja, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe Abitur gemacht vor zwei Jahren, da war alles in Ordnung.
Und jetzt nach dieser Ausbildung, das ist meine letzte Prüfung, wissen Sie nächste Woche,
wenn irgendwie habe ich mir glaube ich zu viel Stress gemacht.
Okay, haben Sie damit das die Herzstoppen oder Herzrasen haben?
Ja, Herzrasen habe ich immer wieder, ja das stimmt, es klopft manchmal kräftig.
Ja, Herzrasen, haben Sie Ihr Herzfrequenz messen oder?
Nee, habe ich jetzt nicht, aber ich merke, dass es manchmal nicht immer, aber manchmal
ganz schnell schlägt, aber dann geht es wieder.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es ist ganz kräftig.
Okay, okay.
Geht ganz kräftig.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Todstgefühl?
Unter was?
Todst Angst?
Bisher nichts bekannt, habe ich bisher nur nie gehabt.
Eigentlich habe ich mich auch ganz gut auf die Prüfung vorbereitet,
also so große Angst habe ich vor der Prüfung jetzt nicht, aber...
Aber ich kann es auch nicht sagen, was das Problem ist.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Sodbrennen?
Sodbrennen, nein.
Ich habe nur in den letzten Tagen kaum Hunger gehabt, habe wenig gegessen.
Und auch wenig getrunken, aber Sodbrennen habe ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Haben Sie bisher ein Arzt des Regenbesuch?
Nein, Sie sind der erste Arzt jetzt, nein.
Okay.
So, Frau Körter.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen für Ihre Vorgeschichte stellen.
Ganz, ich bitte schön.
Keine Krankheiten?
Nein, also ich hatte bisher nie etwas gehabt, keine Medikamente, sind auch keine Allergien
bekannt.
Ich war wieder beim Hausarzt, das war bisher alles in Ordnung, also ich habe eigentlich
nichts.
Okay.
Das war ordentlich.
Wann war es beim Hausarzt?
Vor einem Jahr.
Ja, Frau Körter, ich habe Ihre Beschwerden verstanden, ich werde mir gleich um Ihre
Beschwerden kommen.
Aber jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen für Ihre allgemeinen Gesundheit begonnen.
Ja.
Und?
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie kein mehr Appetit haben, habe ich recht?
Nein, in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie ab oder zu gewinnen?
Nein, alles gleich.
Ich habe zwei, drei Tage, war alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich viel brich?
Bitte?
Fieber? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stifl rust oder nachtweiß?
Nein, ich konnte nur schlecht schlafen, beziehungsweise ich bin immer wach geworden
und bin auch ziemlich müde.
Warum müssen Sie aufwachen wegen?
Den Nachtwahl, ich bin immer ständig wach, ich schlafe ein, aber ich werde immer wieder wach.
Durch Schlaf und Probleme haben Sie?
Ja.
Haben Sie etwas versucht für diese Beschwerden?
Ich meine...
Ich habe nichts eingenommen, deswegen bin ich heute bei Ihnen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es etwas Schlimmes oder das Gefährlich ist.
Ich denke, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen stressig ist, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Deswegen bin ich hier.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, nein, war nichts. Nein.
Okay.
Ich muss alles dokumentieren, was Sie erwähnen.
Ich besiege einige...
Ja, Frau Kantar, ich bitte Sie,
in diesem...
Jetzt werde ich Sie eine Tüte geben,
und ich bitte Sie um diese Tüte ein- und ausatmen.
Können Sie das versuchen?
In die Tüte?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, können Sie in die Tüte einatmen und ausatmen.
Dann können wir unsere Gespräche vorsetzen.
Ja, können Sie bitte das sehen mal.
Sie sehen mal?
Ja.
Okay, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Vielen Dank, das wird, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser.
Ja, Sie können fortsetzen und...
Ja, Herr Kantar, Sie haben ermet,
dass Sie keine vorheriger Erkrankungen haben.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich glaube schon, also mein Haushaltsatzeingepunkt,
der ist jetzt sehr kontrolliert.
Die müssten alle komplett sein.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Seite...
in Land oder aus Land gereist?
Nein, mache ich nicht fragen.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Kantar, jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer...
gynäkologischen Annämeness.
Ist Ihr Monatbrüttin krigelmesi?
Ja, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Da ist in Ordnung, ja.
Okay.
Frau Kantar, rachen Sie?
Nein.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Also nur bei ähnlichen Partys, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nein.
Wie viel nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Wie gesagt, sehr selten.
Sehr selten.
Nein oder so, aber nicht.
Aber das wie gesagt nur bei Veranstaltungen.
Oder wenn eine fest ist.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein.
Aber ich habe es ja noch nicht probiert.
Okay.
Bleiben Sie Sport?
Ja, also ich gehe regelmäßig ins Fitnessstudio.
Zweimal die Woche.
Fitnessstudio.
Ja.
Ansonsten.
Ansonsten spiele ich manchmal Tennis.
Tennis.
Okay.
Frau Kantar, wir sind bautfertig.
Nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familienvorgeschichte.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch nicht nehmen?
Ja, ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Sind Sie bei der
Ihre Vater-Krankheiten bekannt?
Ich weiß nicht, aber
der hat glaube ich einen leichten, hohen Blutdruck.
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Leidet Ihre Mutter an Irgendwelte Erklankungen?
Nein, soweit ich weiß, ich meine Mutter auch nicht so leidet.
Sie hat keine Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja.
Ich habe eine jüngere Schwester, sie ist 17 Jahre alt.
Schwester, 17 Jahre alt.
Ist sie jetzt?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie allein oder haben Sie eine feste Partner?
Ich bin alleine, ich habe keinen Freund.
Und wegen den Prüfungen wohne ich jetzt in einer anderen Wohnung,
nicht bei meinen Eltern, damit ich besser auf die Prüfungen vorbereiten konnte.
Aber normalerweise ohne Sie mit...
Bei meinen Eltern, ja.
Seit wann wohnen Sie in einer anderen Wohnung?
Ja, seit halbem Jahr wegen den Prüfungen.
Okay, seit halbem Jahr wegen Prüfungen.
So, Sie sind Schülerin oder...
Ich mache eine Ausbildung.
Ausbildung, okay.
In welchem Bereich machen Sie eine Ausbildung?
Als Bürokaufraun.
Bürokaufraun.
Ja, wie ich verstanden habe, ist bei Ihnen stressig und stressbekannt.
Also normalerweise habe ich ein bisschen...
Haben Sie Stress bei...
Vor den Prüfungen war das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen viel Stress.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Kantha, meinerseits habe ich wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Haben Sie etwas hinzufügen, dass ich wissen sollte?
Also, ich habe jetzt sonst nichts dazu zu sagen.
Können Sie mir irgendwas geben,
dass diese Symptome etwas nachlassen
und ich wieder ein bisschen normal schlafen kann?
Ist das etwas Schlimmes?
Aber deswegen bin ich jetzt heute hier.
Ja, okay.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, habe ich die Informationen bekommen,
aber alle Maßnahmen sind wichtig für uns.
Zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen
und dann natürlich kann ich Ihnen einige Medikamente verordnen.
Machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Sie sind ganz nett und ein freundlicher Doktor.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, Sie sind auch.
Eigentlich schon.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Bitte.
Frau Kantha, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit
etwas eingenommen, um besser zu konzentrieren für die Prüfungen?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe gestern ein bisschen Ibuprofen genommen,
weil ich Schmerzen an den Händen hatte.
Aber nichts pflanzliche oder...
Nein, nein, mache ich noch mal, weiß ich nicht.
Nein.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Wie? Einmal?
Luft, Luftunga oder?
Luftunga?
Ja, Luftunga.
Luft, weniger Luft bemerkete.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe wenig Luft
und bekomme ganz schlecht Luft.
Luftnot.
Luftnot bemerkete.
Ja, deswegen bin ich hier.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Nein, bisher noch nicht, nein.
Und um Verträglichkeit?
Frau Kantha, wann war Ihre letzte Bejude?
Das ist ungefähr, zwei Wochen ungefähr her.
Perhütchen Sie, nehmen Sie Pilze?
Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente hinein.
Okay, danke.
Ich rauche auch nicht.
Sie sind Sportlerin.
Seit zwei bis drei Tagen haben Sie Sport gemacht?
Ja, ich habe jetzt zuletzt, wann war das vor vier Tagen ungefähr?
Da war ich nochmal im Fitnessstudio.
Sie werden beschwerden bei Belastung oder nur?
Wie gesagt, das ist erst jetzt seit ein, zwei Tagen.
Normalerweise habe ich das nicht.
Können Sie mich werden auf Nacht auftreten?
Manchmal, wie gesagt, erst seit gestern oder seit vorgestern.
Ich habe einfach nur schlecht geschlafen.
Ich war ständig, wach immer wieder.
Haben Sie Verletzt oder Unfall in der Zeit?
Nein, Unfall habe ich jetzt.
Nein.
Danke.
Unsere Kollegen geben das Daten nicht, nicht gefragt.
Genau.
Aber das steht in den Aufnahmedaten drin.
In der Patientinakte.
Können wir erst als Kindespreis anfangen, Herr Kollege?
Ich denke, alle fragen, ich denke, keine.
Der Doktor ist nicht da?
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberhass.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Guten Abend, lieber Umut.
Erzähl doch bitte mal, was hast du denn für einen Patienten?
Ja, die Patientin heißt Frau Sarakanta.
Frau Kantha ist 22 Jahre alt, 1,72 m groß und wiegt 45 kg.
Sie macht eine Ausbildung im Bereich von Druhkaufmann.
Und Sie haben...
Kauffrau?
Kauffrau, ja Kauffrau.
Sie hat uns seit 3 Tagen bestehende Dispner,
Unruhe und Angstgefühl vorgestellt.
Sie hat berichtet, dass sie in Hände, Füße und Wander
und Herzpopen leiden.
Papitation in Tahikardi haben.
Todesangst, Pyrosis wurden bei der Patientin verneidt.
Sie hat auch erwähnt, dass die Beschwerden erstes Mal auftreten seien.
Auftreten.
Auftreten seien.
Vor einem Jahr war sie bei Hausarzt und laut Hausarzt
alles in Ordnung gewesen.
Sie war nicht gereist.
Die gynecologische Anämpfung war auch unabhängig.
Sie war keine Raucherin und Alkoholkonsum beträgt gelegentlich,
nur beim Veranstaltungen.
Sie haben keine Erfahrung mit dem Alkoholkonsum,
nehmen Sie nur beim Veranstaltungen.
Nehmen Sie beim Veranstaltungen zu sich.
Sie haben keine Erfahrung mit dem Drogen.
Sie treiben regelmäßig Sport.
Sie gehen 2 Mal pro Woche Fitnessstudio
und gelegentlich Spiele-Tennis.
Spiele-Tennis, ja.
Spiele-Tennis.
Sie haben auch eine EKG-Schreibung.
Machen Sie bei den Labo-Werten auch die D-Dimäre mit?
Ja, ich habe keine Differenzialdiagnose auf pulmonäre Emblemüs,
weil ich keine Risikofaktoren habe.
Sie haben keine Piläre.
Das ist richtig, aber Sie haben Wartenschmerzen angegeben.
Sie haben Luftnot.
Wenn Sie schon Blut abnehmen,
dann macht es Sinn, auch die D-Dimäre mitzukontrollieren.
Das ist richtig.
Es gibt 2 Risikofaktoren.
Fruchtbar und weiblich.
Und möglich, wenn es möglich ist.
Vielleicht hat sie auch eine Tumelkrankung,
das wir ein bisschen nicht wissen.
Das kann ja auch sein.
Also ich möchte die D-Dimäre trotzdem machen.
Ja, okay.
Und ich würde ein psychiatrisches Konsul anfordern.
Ja, sollte sich die D-Dimäre bestätigen,
schlage ich Psychotherapeutin oder Metapoleurin.
Was geben Sie für die Akut-Situation, was wäre da hilfreich?
Sie haben ja schon eine Tüte gegeben, das war ja schon sehr gut.
Ich würde auch eine kurzfristige Benzodiazepine.
Was würden Sie geben?
Alprazolam oder Alprazolam?
Ja, Alprazolam.
Aber eher Alprazolam, was man hier gerne gibt,
ist meistens Loracepan, das Tavo.
Ja, Loracepan.
Also mit Alprazolam ist eher so in der Anästhesie
oder bei Schmerztherapien vielleicht.
Das gibt man bei Jugendfreunden nicht unbedingt.
Aber Alprazolam kann man auch probieren.
Aber sehr gängig, oder was man sehr oft gerne gibt,
ist das Tavo Loracepan.
Das hilft oft auch sehr gut.
Loracepan ist das, wie ein okay Tavo.
Genau, Tavo. Das ist Loracepan, das ist der Wirkstoff.
Ja, okay.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Das haben Sie, glaube ich, ganz gut gemacht.
Der Patientin geht ja schon auch viel, viel besser.
Das sieht man sehr oft bei jungen Menschen,
nicht nur Frauen, sondern auch bei jungen Männern.
Dass sie bei Stresssituationen
oft eine Ahnig-Situation bekommen.
Aber das haben Sie sehr gut herausgefunden.
Vielen Dank.
Bei der Prüfung muss man, wenn man das Geschenk unterbrechen,
muss man Tüte geben oder nicht.
Können Sie natürlich schon machen, wenn Sie sagen,
probieren Sie mal die Tüte.
Vielleicht hilft es Ihnen.
Das kann Sie schon sagen, natürlich.
Klar. Also das war jetzt eine junge Patientin.
Oder hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ich wollte das noch mal ein bisschen ausholen erzählen.
Die Aufnahme können wir wahrscheinlich auch abbrechen.
Aber in jedem Fall, im ersten denier eine Blutgasanalyse.
Genau, das kann man auch machen,
wenn man das hat in der Notaufnahme.
Meistens hat man das in der Notaufnahme.
Ich habe das in der Haushaltspraxis nicht.
Also das war ja wirklich eine Patientin von heute Morgen,
die genau mit diesen Symptomen.
Genau so saß sie da auf dem Stuhl.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat Stress.
Und war eigentlich eine ganz typische Panik-Attacke.
Die periorale Kribbelparistisie,
Tätanin an den Händen, Kremfe an den Füßen.
Das kann bis hin zur Bewusstlichkeit gehen.
Das sieht meistens immer sehr dramatisch aus.
Aber ist eigentlich sehr harmlos.
Als Differenzialdiagnose meine ich,
während der Prüfung muss man auch Pinoe-Motorhax erwähnen.
Kann man natürlich auch eine Differenzialdiagnose sein.
Spontanen-Motorhax.
Da würde man natürlich die Lunge abhorchen,
Blutgas oder Sauerstoff-Setigung messen.
Wenn es geht die Blutgase,
dann muss man das noch mal ein bisschen zuordnen.
Aber sie haben mir das sehr gemacht.
Sie haben auf die Lunge gehört. Die Lunge war komplett gut belüftet.
Die Sauerstoff-Setigung war sehr gut.
Also ist im Prinzip die Wahrscheinlichkeit
oder die Verdachtstereit in unserem Pinoe-Motorhax,
könnte man relativ schnell ausschließen.
Aber um das vielleicht noch mal zu bestätigen
oder auszuschließen,
können wir noch mal einen Röntgen-Torhax erst mal machen.
Oder während der Untersuchung.
Ja, und man hat besüglich diese Geburtstatus.
Es ist nicht so bekannt im Kassur.
Und haben wir nicht im Kurs gefragt.
Es gibt keine Platz für Geburtstatus in Kassur,
sondern es gibt eine Anämpfung.
Der hat deshalb die Frage nicht.
Manchmal haben Sie erwähnt, dass ich fragen muss.
Letztes Mal habe ich gefragt,
ob Sie mich empfohlen haben.
Weil Sie mir empfohlen haben.
Aber heute habe ich vergessen zu fragen.
Sehr gut.
Aber wenn Sie mich empfohlen,
werde ich bei der Prüfung fragen.
Alles klar.